hello everyone and welcome i'm very
happy to be presenting today and talking
about
engaging in opioid use disorder stigma
reduction and giving you a brief
overview of some really excellent
resources and ways to reduce stigma for
the opioid crisis
my name is dr ashley yoger and i am a
professional practice extension
assistant professor in health and
wellness at utah state university
extension
i want to get us started with just a
brief outline of what we're going to
talk about we're going to do a quick
review of opioids and the opioid crisis
so that we all know
what we're talking about and having a
framework of reference for what i'm
discussing we'll talk also next about
stigma and do an overview of what stigma
is
as well as talking about ways to combat
stigma and using non-stigmatizing
language as a specific example of
a really evidence-based way to reduce
stigma for the opioid use disorder
crisis that we're facing and then we'll
talk briefly about some
evidence-based disorder opioid disorder
treatments and talk about those as well
as some key takeaways and things that
you can really implement today after
you've seen this presentation and i also
look forward to seeing and responding to
any questions comments that you might
have
and really i'm available after the
presentation as well
so just to talk briefly about what
opioids are
they're a highly habit-forming class of
chemicals used to reduce the intensity
and feeling of pain there's some common
examples a lot of these are prescription
medications so things like oxycodone
codeine morphine vicodin percocet
fentanyl there's also synthetic fentanyl
and heroin that people use illicitly as
well as misusing some of these
prescription medications so by misuse
when i say that i mean they use either
more or more often than directed by
their prescription and their doctor or
they're using without a prescription and
80 percent of people who use heroin
first misuse a opioid prescription that
they receive from their doctor and so
that's something that we just really
want to
hit home today and talking about why
we're concerned with this because you
can see the majority of people who have
misused opiates in the past year
have been people who are using opioid
pain relievers and so that you can see
on this chart here this graph very few
people are using exclusively heroin that
illicit substance and when i'm talking
about substance use disorders including
opioid use disorder i'm talking about
treatable mental health conditions in
which there's a pattern of substance use
that leads to impairment distress
in their social occupational and or
familial settings so that's something
that we'll talk briefly about
as well as we move forward i just wanted
us all to have
the same definitions and again
most people you can see the red arrow
now pointing to that blue circle
misuse
just opioid pain relievers so that
prescription medication
the opioid crisis when we talk about
this you've probably heard it a lot in
the past several years but this is
actually not our first opioid crisis um
we started opioid crises back way way
back long ago
when our medical providers were telling
us that there was no danger in using
opioids and that they were safe to
prescribe and there was no issue in
prescribing opioid medication however we
that was a misinterpretation of the
evidence and is not
the case because we now know the highly
habit-forming
effects of opioids and the complications
that come with that and with the opioid
crisis
i just wanted to give you a few simple
facts that you can take from our
presentation today about 1.6 million
people experienced opioid use disorder
in 2019 this is data from samsa so you
can also go and look up any of this
information that i'm talking about
and kind of take a deeper dive if you're
interested and of those people um in
substance use disorder treatment overall
so not just people with opioid use
disorder only 12 percent that's about
one in ten people who need substance use
disorder treatment are getting their
treatment um and that was in 2019
and
as going along with our opioid crisis
data about 841 000 people die from
overdose
since 1999 we've lost a lot of lives and
that equates to in recent years twice as
many people
dying from substance related overdoses
than car accidents and that's a really
staggering statistic if we think about
it and that's about 71 000 deaths in
2019 over two-thirds of which have been
opioid related and about 185 deaths a
day if we're thinking about it in that
way and something else that we wanted to
just briefly mention is that people are
receiving these medications and opioids
right if you look at this chart here you
can see where they're getting their
medications from and you can see i'm
going to have a little red line show up
right here most people over 50 percent
get prescription medication either given
to them or from a loved one's cabinet
so this is something that we're going to
talk about towards the end but it's
really important even though sometimes
people have the best of intentions of
sharing their old medications or might
not even know they're in their cabinets
we just had a national dea take back day
it's really important to
put your medications and get rid of them
to a authorized dropbox location
whenever you're done with them and don't
hold on to your old or unused
medications and don't share them with a
loved one you can see on this chart most
people do
get those medications from loved ones
friends family members
and then talking a little bit about the
opioid overdose crisis you can see
deaths in each state here this is per
100 000 people and you can just see it's
kind of a heat map so the lighter color
indicates fewer people per hundred
thousand and the darker color to green
indicates more people per hundred
thousand and you can see some regional
sort of differences throughout the
united states and looking closer at
opioid-specific overdoses you can see
again these percentages of those
substance use overdoses that you can see
going from again lighter to darker like
a heat map how many of those involve
opioids and here you can really see some
regional differences and how many of
those deaths involved opioids and that's
a staggering number so this is just
something i wanted to show
and just give you an idea of how many of
those deaths are a result of opioids and
one of the big pieces of the opioid
crisis is stigma and when i have done
word cloud activities this is an example
of what i've done in the past these are
things that people say come to mind when
they hear the word stigma so things like
snap judgment prejudice something that's
negative bias these are some of those
quick words that come to mind when
you're thinking of stigma and it
encompasses all of those things and when
we're thinking about stigma
we can talk about it in a way that we're
referring to a group of people
often including different public
policies that are directed at that group
of people and they we break it down into
three main categories typically that's
social stigma structural stigma and
self-stigma social stigma is at groups
and boosting stereotypes of those
individuals structural stigma is
negative attitudes and behaviors that
represent larger groups so kind of that
structural basis
and self-stigma is when people actually
internalize these negative views and
hold them towards themselves and i like
this quote at the bottom that stigma is
being reduced from a whole and usual
person to a tainted discounted one
because that is what stigma serves to do
for people and it can be a really big
barrier for individuals with substance
use disorder and opioid use disorder to
getting the treatment that they need and
that they can use to engage in recovery
and here's an example of
how stigma increases harm it can cause
fear prejudice discrimination it reduces
their quality of health care and can
really uh play a role there in them even
seeking health care it can have negative
impacts on their self their hope
it increases the likelihood of return to
substance use and lower rates of
recovery and it's a very destructive
cycle for people you can see in this
cycle it starts with public stigma and
goes to discrimination fear prejudice
and that damages someone's self-esteem
and their likelihood of seeking
treatment which then in turn increases
self-stigma shame and doubt and reduced
rates of recovery dropping out of
treatment and that might
trigger a return to substance use and
some of those other negative
consequences that stigma causes
when we're talking specifically about
opioid use disorder stigma and how to
start reducing that now that we've
talked about some of the major
components
we have talked about four evidence-based
ways to reduce stigma and the first one
is basing things on education and real
life stories research has shown that if
we enhance education about people with
opioid use disorder we can really reduce
some of that stigma and people can learn
that opioid use disorder is a treatable
medical condition and that people do
recover
and that is something that's really
great and something that we can share as
well as real life stories of people
because education alone and fact sheets
and just giving people a lot of
information by itself is not enough to
actually change or reduce stigma so
something that comes with that education
is applying some real life stories and
education with that
also these stories we want them to be
positive and people if you have positive
interactions with people in recovery
that can really help improve the
attitude of the general public that
social stigma and using non-stigmatizing
language in these examples and these
stories can be really helpful one to
model this skill but also to help people
understand and feel comfortable and safe
in an environment where they're talking
about recovery
or their experience with substance use
disorder and something like that can
really change people's path to recovery
and help them where they are if they're
not in recovery yet it can lay the
framework and the foundation for them
seeking recovery in the future and so
that's something really important to
talk about and we'll talk about that on
the next slide as well
um the next thing here for opioid use
disorder stigma reduction if we're
talking about
self stigma something that's really
effective are things like acceptance and
commitment therapy groups and job
training this counseling and vocational
training can help reduce self stigma and
really encourage or support an
individual's recovery because they learn
to see themselves as a whole person
and these different trainings can
improve their self-concept and really
bolster their recovery efforts because
that they are valued and supported
and lastly um just as a few examples
this is a shortened list there are more
examples of opioid use disorder stigma
reduction but these are some of the big
ones and these strategies can be really
helpful
if we really focus on empathy and
compassion changing our narratives that
we say and talking about people who are
in recovery or people with opioid use
disorder and changing that with with
reducing our stigma through acceptance
and mindfulness and awareness of the way
that we are speaking is really really
helpful
including just simple phrases and things
that people say often but can harm
someone's recovery and their efforts and
so as a quick example i'd like to just
give some common non-stigmatizing
replacements for language and just hit
home that what we say really really
matters in our treatment settings in our
settings with people in public health
and in your family and home settings as
well because if we can talk to people as
humans first
then we can start to change the stigma
and help people find the resources when
they're ready and
help them to maintain their recovery so
one quick example that i hear often and
is kind of the most common is changing
from addict or addiction and dirty to a
person with a substance use disorder or
a person who tests positive for
substances
if we're talking about testing and those
types of things so again if you notice
this person first language you put the
person first so you say a person with
substance use disorder a person with
opioid use disorder
former addict getting clean right those
are another example of some stigmatizing
phrases that people
often use and instead you would say a
person
in recovery or someone who is testing
negative for substances
clean sober right a lot of times we have
these negative association words that
come with it implying that someone with
opioid use disorder or substance use
disorder
is dirty uh or
immoral or something like that and we
can really shift our language to saying
substance free
treatment is the goal
it doesn't sound stigmatizing
at the onset right but honestly we can
shift our language to say treatment is
one path to recovery not every person
wants to or can engage in treatment so
it is one path and recovery does not
look the same for all people it is
there's not one size fits all for a
recovery path so that's something that's
really important to remember as well
and opioid replacement or opioid
management we don't like to use those
words we would focus more on medication
assisted treatment or medication for
opioid use disorder m-o-u-d or m-a-t
are some common phrases that are
non-stigmatizing
and lastly one that is used often is
relapse and that can be really
stigmatizing to people who are in
recovery so what we would say instead
and kind of framing this to people with
say recurrence or return return to
substance use so replacing some of those
common phrases that we've heard over and
over again to phrases that are more
person-first and compassionate and
empathetic to encourage recovery and
reduce stigma and it's okay if we've
made these mistakes in the past our goal
is to recognize and be mindful and shift
them in the future and start to show
people that we can change this language
it's definitely possible
the next piece that i wanted to talk
about specifically is evidence-based
treatment so
treatment does work it's effective it's
evidence-based and recovery is possible
treatment works best when you have a
whole person approach that includes the
biopsychosocial model so that includes
things like biological backgrounds
injuries genetics those type of things
psychological history so
any um
triggers coping skills where people are
at right now past traumas and then
social uh settings and social things
like family life and communities that
they're in peers and these all have
interactions that are very complex
there's not one single
thing or aspect of a person that causes
a substance use disorder it's not a
simple issue there's all these things
that are interactive so when we're
talking about treatment and recovery we
want to make sure that we're talking
about a whole person because that is
what's most effective and some specific
examples of some evidence-based
treatment models include cognitive
behavioral therapy that focuses on
thoughts behaviors and feelings and
increasing coping skills and replacing
some of those negative thoughts or
things that are no longer serving the
person with more adaptive skills
motivational interviewing which includes
non-judgmental interviews and guiding
the person helping them to understand
their own goals
and motivations
mindfulness-based stress reduction or
mbsr which includes mindfulness and
awareness and helping the person to
identify triggers and engaging in
healthy coping skills in those moments
and lastly just on our quick list of
examples here this is not an exhaustive
list is acceptance and commitment
therapy or act
and that is really values based and
focuses on a lot of mindfulness and
being present in the moment and using
skills and replacing some of those
skills that are healthy with things that
you can use in the moment and not using
the unhealthy skills or things that you
have used in the past for coping such as
substances
again briefly talking about moud
medications for opioid use disorder when
you combine these with behavioral
counseling and some of those
evidence-based treatments that i
mentioned for a whole patient approach
it reduces opioid overdose deaths
substantially it's evidence-based and
it's very important for people to get
into those treatments if it's something
that they would like to do so stigma
reduction is one way that we can
encourage recovery and effective
evidence-based treatment and talking
about medication for opioid use disorder
is another way that we can help people
to understand these evidence-based
treatments for individuals with opioid
use disorder as well
and talking about them in ways that we
can really increase their acceptance and
um use because they are one of our harm
reduction tools and evidence-based ways
for treating opioid use disorder
including things like methadone
buprenorphine or suboxone and naltrexone
and so i'm just going to continue on and
talking about oh and also vivitrol um
with that so
talking about some key takeaways here
after we've reviewed the opioid crisis
stigma and how to reduce it and then
some evidence-based treatments for
opioid use disorder i think it really
shows that we are all in this together
it is very common for people to start
taking opioid medications and
i know several people who have had
babies and been prescribed opioid
medications after their c-section and
they continue to take those medications
even though they may or may not need
them but their doctor prescribes them so
they're going to take them because they
were under the impression that they just
keep taking them and that's something
that they're supposed to do until
they're gone and after about five to
seven days people can become dependent
on their opioid medications and so we're
really
all in this together from moms doctors
right everybody can play a role in
preventing opioid use disorder from
yourself from others medical providers
each of us has a role to play
in reducing opioid use disorder and
stigma and i want you to think just one
thing that you can do and i have a few
examples of some things that you can do
today after this presentation some
action items for you and thinking about
that mom or right that person who you
know that loved one that child who broke
their arm and is exposed to opioids what
are some things that we can do we can
really focus on prevention so if you
don't need an opioid medication don't
take one talk to your doctor and if you
are a medical provider talk to your
patients about their past risk factors
are they somebody with a substance use
disorder maybe an opioid medication is
not right for them where some other type
of medication would be right or doing
some type of alternative
pain management therapy so things like
cognitive behavioral therapy are really
effective for managing pain or
mindfulness based
intervention so not taking opioids is
one
one factor in reducing that risk so is
medication disposal and i mentioned at
the beginning that 50 of people who
misuse opioid medication get them from a
loved one so getting those medications
out of your house and into the correct
drop boxes is really important we can
also talk about harm reduction as
something that you can discuss and do
today right so reducing those
undesirable consequences to make a path
for when people are ready for recovery
so things like naloxone where if
somebody has an overdose naloxone can
reverse the effects of that overdose
temporarily so something that's really
important is to
provide and to have on hand naloxone or
narcan for people who do get opioid
prescriptions or who are using illicit
opiates
like heroin or fentanyl because when
people survive they do go into recovery
and you can't recover if you overdose
and you are not revived so that's
something that's really important that i
want to hit home is that harm reduction
is another evidence-based way to help
support people into recovery
and then treatment and recovery like i
mentioned there's no one-stop shop it
takes a lot of time something you can do
today is reaching out to a loved one or
somebody that you care about saying hey
how's it going checking in offering to
take them to a appointment or give
giving them resources and i have a list
of national resources coming up towards
the end here that can help get you
started in finding resources to provide
to a loved one and offering them that
support and help when they're ready on
their path to recovery and finally
something that seems simple but makes a
really big difference is sharing
teaching others about what you've
learned today about stigma reduction and
evidence-based treatment
one example of that is the stories of
utah's opioid crisis we have some
wonderful
qualitative interviews that are all
housed online that you're welcome to
search and listen to that talk a lot
about recovery and hope and how people
found that pathway specifically in utah
so we'd love to have people look at that
and other national opioid use disorder
resources these are some common lists of
places that i like to send uh people to
to just get an idea of okay i have a
loved one who needs support where can i
send them the american psychological
association or apa has a lot of great
substance use related resources so if
you click or search that link
that would be a wonderful place to start
the cdc also has a lot of really
wonderful information on opioids
including research current statistics
and also recovery and treatment sort
resources for you so if you go to
cdc.gov you can find that on their
opioids page and then the national
alliance on mental illness or nami you
can go there and look about mental
illness and other mental health
disorders including substance use
disorders and they have a lot of
information there for substance use
related disorders and then national
institute on drug abuse or nida has some
good information on that topic and you
can look there as well and then samsa
the substance abuse and mental health
services administration has a wonderful
treatment locator that you can direct
people to as well as an opioid overdose
prevention tool kit if you wanted to
look into well how do i start
implementing some of these things into
my community what can i do
and so that's a really great
place to start if you're wanting to get
more involved with opioid use disorder
prevention
treatment and recovery
i would like to say thank you and
encourage you to reach out if you have
future questions concerns or would like
more resources i'm happy to provide
those you can also follow us
the health extension advocacy and
research
and teaching initiative also known as
heart
at utah state university extension is
explicitly focused on opioids and you
can follow our social media here to stay
connected we also have a youtube channel
where we post some general health and
wellness information as well as opioid
related information
and just to show you very quickly we
have some select references
and resources that you are welcome to
look at in the future after this
recorded presentation and i again want
to say
thank you for your time in learning
about opioid use disorder and stigma
reduction we each have a part to play in
reducing the opioid crisis and stigma
reduction is one way
in which we can encourage evidence-based
treatment prevention recovery and put an
end to this crisis
and treat people like people
treatment works
and recovery is possible thank you